[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro Cordero 20 años después de su
primera Victoria receta allí perdogan
quiere ser reelegido este 14 de mayo
para un nuevo mandato enfrente tiene a
una oposición que pretende terminar con
dos décadas de poder en las que se ha
priorizado el ultranacionalismo el
islamismo y un marcado personalismo en
torno a la figura del presidente algo
que no hará fácil la victoria opositora
a pesar de contar con aspectos a favor
como la profunda crisis económica y la
mala gestión del gobierno en el
terremoto que asoló el sureste de
Turquía el pasado febrero Pero cómo
alcanzó erdogan Tanto poder en este
tiempo
su ascenso a la jefatura de gobierno en
2003 fue histórico erdogan un reconocido
islamista ganó unos comicios
parlamentarios en una nación que se
había distinguido durante el siglo XX
por ser un ejemplo de secularismo y lo
hizo gracias a una fuerte crítica de la
gestión estatal del terremoto que asoló
a la ciudad de Smith en 1999 un sismo
que dejó más de 17.000 muertos y a un
discurso europeísta que contrasta con
sus posturas actuales así hablaba Poco
después de ser elegido
dado que la mayoría de la población
turca es musulmana el éxito Turco en el
proceso de la Unión Europea será un gran
ejemplo para otros países musulmanes y
mostrará como la democracia puede
convivir muy bien con el islam
como un gobierno muy claro y competente
erdogan Comenzó desde sus inicios a
deconstruir un estado levantado durante
décadas en la base del kemalismo es
decir la neutralidad internacional el
acercamiento a occidente y la laicidad
en todos los ámbitos públicos y lo hizo
gracias a un discurso populista que
funcionaba entre la población rural y la
clase trabajadora erdogan se mostraba
como un político de valores islámicos y
de orígenes Humildes algo que le ayudó a
ser reelegido en 2007 y 2011 Durante los
primeros años prácticamente nadie
cuestionó su talante democrático pero la
situación cambió Una vez que se
iniciaron las protestas en el parque
guesi de Estambul en junio del año 2013
lo que comenzó como una manifestación
ecologista contra la destrucción de este
espacio fue contestado con violencia
policial y represión gubernamental algo
que fue duramente criticado y que
generalizó la movilización en las
principales ciudades del país contra los
10 años de gobierno que por esa época
llevaban el poder erdogan
Nadie puede invadir el parque hemos sido
pacientes hasta ahora pero se nos está
acabando la paciencia Este es mi última
advertencia hago un llamado a madres y
padres por favor hagan algo con sus
hijos
pero esto no trajo muchos cambios
erdogan se presentó a la presidencia en
2014 y obtuvo la victoria el primer paso
en su deriva autoritaria que se
confirmaría tras el intento de golpe de
estado en su contra en julio de 2016 en
esa sublevación una parte del ejército
intentó derrocarlo sin éxito
produciéndose unos 290 fallecidos en
apenas dos días el oficialismo acusó al
teólogo fetula gulent antiguo Aliado de
erdogan de instigarlo pero lo cierto Es
que este evento propició que erdogan
acometiera las reformas que llevaba años
esperando esta se aprobaron a través de
un referendo que salió con el 51,4% de
los votos y que consistía en la de una
república presidencialista que llevaría
Un aumento del Poder del jefe del estado
y que además significaría una reducción
del Poder del parlamento dentro de esta
República además esta elección
presidencial haría que la mitad de los
jueces del tribunal constitucional
fuesen elegidos directamente por erdogan
y ampliaría el mandato a 5 años de cada
término presidencial facultades que
facilitaron el aumento de la represión
contra los opositores y medios de
comunicación críticos Durante los
siguientes años en materia internacional
se alejó de sus aliados occidentales y
mantuvo una agresiva acción exterior en
medio oriente y África lugares donde ha
intentado convertirse en una potencia
regional a través de su intervención en
conflictos como la guerra civil Siria la
guerra civil Libia o el conflicto entre
azerbaiyán y Armenia por nagorno carabaj
situaciones a las que se suma la crisis
de refugiados hacia Europa en la que
Turquía se ha convertido en un estado
tapón de flujos migratorios a cambio de
cuantiosas cantidades económicas un
acuerdo cuestionable que entró en marcha
tras la crisis de 2015 provocada por la
inestabilidad en medio oriente pero que
es de una fragilidad extrema ya que
erdogan lo ha usado en varias ocasiones
como método de presión a Bruselas
[Música]
Turquía ha aceptado el acuerdo de
refugiados de la Unión Europea no por
dinero sino para evitar que esas
personas migrantes reciban un trato
despectivo en las fronteras europeas
Desde esa crisis el papel de Turquía
como potencia regional se consolidó al
igual que su figura como mediador entre
las potencias occidentales y otras
potencias como China o Rusia algo que se
ha podido vislumbrar en acuerdos como la
exportación de grano en medio de la
Guerra de Ucrania sin embargo esta hábil
estrategia ambivalente en política
internacional hay que recordar que
Turquía es Aliado de Moscú pero a la vez
es el segundo miembro más importante de
la otan puede que no sea suficiente para
revalidar su poder ya que la profunda
crisis económica que azota a Turquía
desde hace años sumado a su gestión del
terremoto de febrero de 2023 que dejó
casi 48.000 fallecidos podría ser clave
para poner fin a 20 años de erdoganismo
con esto concluimos si quieren conocer
más historias sigan conectados a France
24 y France 24.com
[Música]